the final game in the quarterfinals and
here we go
and we're off it is a queen's pawn
opening and the london system
something that we heard a lot about from
liam quagley earlier on
today hey and you sound excited javanco
i am excited because it's the strategy
that you kind of highlighted that
keeping all the pieces on the board
artemia is going for the long
long drawn out variation where he's just
going to play quickly
and uh yeah flag hikaru
yep and hikaru he knows that he can't
rely
just on the clock uh to survive so
therefore he pushes a pawn he's trying
to create some tension in the center
maybe going slightly aggressive from the
black side
taking as much space as possible and the
first one to flinch the first one to
pause
really is yeah and uh he shouldn't do
this
okay but the clocks have they frozen
no their clocks haven't frozen okay i'll
tell you i'm still thinking 25 second
thing
and he moves a bishop for the second
time in the opening
that's breaking a few rules normally you
only want to move each piece once
and black easily blocks that check okay
well now we have maximum tension
in the center as white challenges
absolutely everything and porn takes
pawn on board
i don't like it for artemiev as white
mostly because his clock advantage is
gone but also
things are getting traded the position
is becoming easier for black to handle
it's less tense now
and therefore easier to play when lower
on the clock
so white bringing his knight out black's
temporarily a point up but white can
recapture that pawn
on that left side any time he wants so
nakamura
he needs to get his king to safety if he
can do that i think he's going to make
the draw
okay black king needs to run away it's
not safe in the center yet
well he's using up some time on his
clock david
three minutes left and it seems to me
it's quite a
normal move to actually just develop the
dark square bishop
and get the king ah okay wow
he plays okay he didn't expect so i said
why can we take the pawn
grab the pawn back any time he wants
hikaru says no
that black bishop has now entrenched
itself in white's territory attacking
whitestroke and defending the pawn
behind it
wow ambitious ambitious stuff by hikaru
he it does come at the cost of
development though peace development and
black's king still in the center
might provoke white i'll tell you if
needing a win into sacrificing
leaving his rook attacked if you move
the rook with white
if you get out of the eyeline of that
bishop then you've lost time so maybe
you just jump into the center with your
knight and he's done it
he's done that okay so well hikara
respected that plan and that's why he's
attacked the light squared bishop
because that pin was a little bit
uncomfortable
um what should you do i mean
i'm looking at bishop takes knight
because
what else to do and then knight takes
bishop but maybe this is a little bit
accommodating
and when i look at the time difference
it's gone
it's almost gone three minutes
for artemyev yeah also three minutes for
ikaru
and uh of course you have to remember
atemf has to win
and remember the last game as well
artemis was low on the clock very early
and hikaru was using that to his
advantage so we do see a trade
bishops and knights have been traded
actually two sets each uh
bishops and knights and now white is in
the lead in development
that is the key everything else is
balanced but black's king is still in
the middle it still needs two moves
you need to move the black bishop and
then scoot your king over to the corner
and
but what does that tell me if thinking
because he should just be centralizing
his rooks move those rooks to the open
lines don't
just use the clock time okay okay he's
accepted an isolated pawn so white
recapturing with his pawn there
rather than going to an end game by
taking that pawn back with his queen
so no queen trade but uh yeah now
there's only one move before black makes
a new
oh well before black hole about this
move you know i'll tell you
really striking in the center
pushing the pawn he had to do it before
it was too late if he hadn't played that
movie if he hadn't opened things up
black's king would run away and whoa the
evaluation bar
says white is winning what white queen
dodges i'm surprised it says it's
winning because it looks good for white
white's about to regain a pawn but
i didn't see it there maybe there were
other squares you could have gone to
with the white queen but okay right now
white's about to regain his porn black
finally castled however
yeah and uh rook takes porn there's
nothing to think about
you could maybe take another porn with
the white queen right now okay that's
just tempting just do it then you just
have to decide yeah
just uh don't spend too much time on the
clock because look at it he
has less time than hikaru yeah he's
lower on the clock now
whoa okay hikaru's allowed the black
queen to be attacked look at all of
white's pieces the rooks the queen the
bishop they're all on fantastic squares
it feels like white has the advantage
but maybe black can uh neutralize that
with accurate play right now white's
bishop is attacked by the black queen
just defend that bishop push up defend
it or move it back
i'll he's pushed a pawn forward yeah his
time advantage
has disappeared but remember artemiev is
the bullet king
he's even beaten players like magnus
carson in the past in bullet chess one
minute chess
so he's capable but it's going to be a
race i think this one is not even going
to come down to the board
um of course nakamura wants to hold
there but he
might well play for the clock okay
white's rook on the seventh rank
that's good we approve yup black bishop
has to move out the way
well maybe you can defend it oh but if
he's scary
if the bishop moves out of the way then
suddenly two white rooks will be
on the seventh row yeah we're gonna see
it look at those two white rooks
lined up black are desperately begging
for a queen trade that's the only way he
can save this game now
and the queen trade has happened
so black needs to trade off one of those
rooks eliminate one of them
together two of them too strong on that
seventh row
okay okay now uh artemia thankfully
speeding
up yeah white has a big advantage here
because
if you compare the rooks white's rook
active attacking pawns black's rook
stuck
defending his own pawns he's trying to
go active now i'm not just that as kings
as well
just take a look white kink and make a
bee line towards the center and start
attacking vulnerable pawns
yeah i yeah nice technique there from
artemis he's fixed all of black's pawns
on dark squares
so those pawns on dart squares will be
easy pickings for the white bishop later
on
and uh okay he attacks black's bishop
next move white's king's going to enter
the center
what do you think winning for white
winning on the board at least yeah
winning on the board
okay in terms of club time uh artemyev
has one and a half
to hikaru is just under one minute and
15 seconds
nice move by artemiev he offers a rook
train if the rooks come off
white is just winning white's king is
better than the black king it's happened
no chance now for nakamura king takes
porn yep
he's a pawn down white king is way
better than the black king
this is just easy for white and with
more than a minute on the clock this
should be
sufficient black's king can not do
anything white's king is going after
that pawn as well he's about to be two
pawns up
take that pawn trade it off yeah and uh
and
uh yeah look how quick suddenly our
tamiya
is he's working up our tamif on the
clock he's 20 seconds up as well
no chance for nakamura no he's going to
be regretting choosing the black pieces
now
it took him too long to defend and i'm
unable to defend on the board
and on the clock not working either
okay all white needs to do is step his
pawn forward at the right moment he uses
his king first
nakamura resigns i'll tell me of us
through to the semi-final
wow what a quarter final match between
these two that was so